el ministro ruso de asuntos exteriores
ha definido el ataque con drones contra
el kermin como un acto hostil y ha
anunciado que habrá consecuencias
acciones concretas por parte de Rusia
Moscú culpa a Ucrania de estar detrás de
esos ataques desde que dicen que ellos
no han tenido nada que ver pero lo más
importante es que Moscú ha elevado La
Apuesta culpando también a Estados
Unidos asegurando que la Casa Blanca
está detrás asegura el ministro ruso
serguilla
nunca hubiese dado ese paso tan
ambicioso sin contar con el permiso de
sus jefes pero la cuestión es si ese
ataque en pleno centro de Moscú puede
ser otro casos beli labrov ha evitado
responder ha dicho que no quería hablar
sobre si son casos belli o no pero sí
que ha dicho que ellos no responderían
con palabras sino con acciones concretas